good afternoon everyone thank you so
much for coming out this afternoon and -
so welcome to all of you - the child
fellowship lecture with our very
distinguished guest dr. hawa update the
lovely its Amalia smoke Somalia's most
celebrated and known physician
humanitarian and human rights activist
and were also extremely delighted to
have dr. Abdi and her daughter
dr. deco Mohammed a similarly important
physician and human rights activist
we're really thrilled to have both of
them back well for deco back at Yale
with us and for dr. Abdi of course the
first time to Yale this is truly an
honor so I want to begin by first asking
everyone to please turn off their cell
phones or any kinds of devices that you
might have just so that we don't disrupt
the conversation today we also ask that
you if you are taking photographs to
probably refrain from doing so
especially with the flashes it's very
bright in here and it's already quite
distracting so that would be very very
helpful so I should pause and introduce
myself I Mary Lou I'm the head of
Timothy Dwight College I'm a professor
in the Department of History and the
program in American Studies as the head
of Timothy Dwight College I have the
honor of serving as the custodian of the
illustrious chubs fellowship established
in 1941 out of a prior large donations
for education purposes made in 1936 by
Henry Chubb who graduated from the class
of 1895 since establishment the Chubb
fund has adhered to the goals of
providing encouragement and aid to Yale
students interested in government and
American public affairs and I'm pleased
to announce this year that we took some
of the Chubb fellowship money and
created summer fellowship for TD
students to engage in the world of
public service and it's really thrilling
we've awarded six Chubb fellowships this
year
and extremely exciting to see what these
students will do so fellowship initially
aimed to foster among Yale
undergraduates and interest in public
service and local and state affairs it
grew over the years to include numerous
distinguished visitors in national and
international affairs as well as leaders
in the world of the arts and humanities
since the 1940s the chubs fellows
lecture series has inspired generations
of Yale students to undertake public
service and pursue leadership roles in
the hopes of using their Yale education
to create a better world today and for
posterity the fellowship has hosted for
u.s. President George HW Bush Gerald
Ford Jimmy Carter and Harry Truman and
in recent years we have welcomed a wide
range of national and international
leaders including Wynton Marsalis Ansan
Suki and Shahrukh Khan it's a great
honor for Timothy Dwight College to
offer this public lecture ship series as
a gift to the Yale University community
as well as the Greater New Haven
community so welcome to all of you to
today's events so with this quick
description of the history and aims of
the chubbs fellowship I'm delighted that
we're welcoming to Yale today dr. hawa
Abdi we're most grateful to her and her
family for working with us since early
January to join us in New Haven and to
be honest when we when we began the
conversations we did not expect for the
spring semesters chubb fellowship
lecture that we would be navigating such
a complicated and difficult legal and
political terrain to bring dr. Abdi into
the United States but we're extremely
thankful that she is here with us today
and I want to take a moment to
acknowledge the many people on this
campus that is here on this campus and
beyond who were very steadfast in their
assistance in bringing dr. Abdi here
first and foremost I wish to
particularly thank president Peter
Saliva's and his office for giving
support Yale University's office of the
general counsel particularly Alex Dreyer
vice president and general counsel and
his wonderful staff of attorneys Kara
Carolyn handle and Susan Sawyer and I
just want the three of them to pop up
for a second and just be acknowledged
for all their amazing work I think I owe
you all some flowers I wish to thank my
colleagues also in the Yale Law School
particularly professor Munir Ahmad for
his advice and support and last but not
least I wish to thank assistant dean
Sarah Lou Lowe who directs the Law
School International Programs and the
Guru programs for global justice and
women's rights
Dean willows ongoing support throughout
the spring has been instrumental in
today's events and I cannot thank her
enough for everything she's done so I
will pause here and introduce two
wonderful people an alum and a current
student to introduce our distinguished
guests for to this afternoon introducing
dr. Abdi and dr. Muhammad will be
Nicholas suku and who graduated from
Yale and Timothy Dwight College in 2016
and senior Charlotte Feingold I've asked
these amazing students to do the honor
of introducing our distinguished guests
because it was niccola's first efforts
that brought the incredible work of
doctors Abdi and Mohammad to my
attention and I can't thank her enough
her for reaching out and telling me
about their amazing work so Mikkel is
originally from Cape Town South Africa
and majored in ethics politics and
economics and participated in the
multidisciplinary academic program in
education studies as a senior she
co-directed the project to design a
human rights and conflict resolution
curriculum for the doctor AB hawa Abdi
foundation after graduating she moved
back to South Africa to work at equal
education a youth-led social movement
that uses research litigation and
activism to fight systemic inequalities
in the South African education system so
we're thrilled to have her back from
South Africa to be here with us today
and Charlotte is from California and a
member of the first class of the
multidisciplinary program in human
rights connected to the Yale Law School
she now directs a team of
who are designing the hope village Human
Rights and conflict resolution
curriculum for the dr. hawa Abdi
foundation please join me in welcoming
Nicola and Charlotte to the podium Thank
You professor Liu we are very grateful
to you and the Chubb fellowship for
giving us the opportunity to introduce
two of our personal heroes
dr. hawa Abdi and her daughter dr. deco
Muhammad for this prestigious event okay
doctor Abdi was born in Mogadishu
Somalia
she studied medicine on a Soviet Union
scholarship and became one of our
country's first gynecologists
while practicing as a doctor that the
Abdi also obtained her law degree nature
she noticed the need for a rural woman's
clinic and established one of those on a
family's land close to Mogadishu for
your she woke up very early to tend to a
farm then traveled to Mogadishu where
she worked full-time as a doctor and
professor of medicine and then
afterwards in the evenings returned home
to see to the line of woman waiting
outside her clinic on a land these women
paid only if they had the means and dr.
Abdi invested all that she had into
maintaining and growing the clinic to
meet the need but following the outbreak
of civil war in Somalia in 1991 the need
became overwhelming as those fleeing the
violence of Mogadishu by foot arrived as
a clinic on mass dr. I be opened up her
land to provide them with medical aid
food clean water and shelter she
stretched her limited resources as far
as she could and it seemed to save the
lives of the hundreds of people that
arrived at the camp daily but in the
first year of the war dr. Ariano team
were forced to bury more than 10,000
people nevertheless she persevered
renamed the hawa Abdi Hope village the
site is now home to over 90,000 people
who live peacefully together if access
to a 400 bed hospital a sustainable
agricultural program a woman's education
center and
primary in high schools doctor Ivy's
2013 memoir keeping hope alive
co-written with Sarah Robbins who's
joined us here today and details our
life of remarkable strength even as the
violence of war famine and poverty took
the lives of so many including some of
those most dearest to her doctor abuse
resilience and resilience of all she has
both if evidence still today at Somalia
where there's yet another terrible
drought hope village is mobilizing to
feed and care for people
dr. Abdi has been recognized in the US
and abroad for her decades of incredible
humanitarian work she is a Nobel Peace
Prize nominee and has received the John
J justice award the Viper voices Woman
of the Year award
BET's social humanitarian award and the
Roosevelt Institute's
freedom from one's award and it is
fitting that she should be honored with
the chap fellowships today dr. Decker
Muhammad and her sister dr. Amin Amin
Hamid have always shared their mother's
vision for hope village and have
assisted in the hospital since they were
teenagers
dr. Decker Mohammed studied medicine in
Moscow she then came to the US as a
refugee where she gained extensive
experience in health care before
returning to Somalia she now runs hope
village and a CEO of the dr. hawa Abdi
foundation she also advises a Somali
Ministry of Health on women and girls
rights her sister now lives in Kenya
where she runs her own women's health
clinic
the partnership between Yale and the
doctor how Abdi foundation began several
years ago and strengthened last fall
when dr. dekha Mohammad was here as a
Greenberg world fellow and teamed up
with Gabriela Hernandez Cardozo another
member of the world fellows class of
2016 and professor James Levinson of the
Jackson Institute for Global Affairs to
design a course in which Yale students
would create a business plan for hope
village this spring graduate and
undergraduate students from across Gayle
are helping Hoke village residents to
identify products that they can
manufacture and sell both inside and
outside of hope village so as to make
the community more sustainable and
Nicola and I are endlessly thankful to
have been entrusted with another project
that had we mentioned that dr. Deku
Muhammad Commission from Yale a human
rights and conflict resolution
curriculum for hope villages new high
school since October 2015 when our team
began working on this task we have had
guidance and support from dr. Decker
Muhammad and her teachers on the ground
as well as from hope Metcalfe and Jim
silk the directors of the shell Center
for International Human Rights and Sarah
Loulou our four-year curriculum rooted
in the history and values of hope
village will get students to think
critically about the history of conflict
in Somalia about what human rights are
and how they can use them to advocate
for change in their community and we are
so proud of the hard work put in by our
team who is also here today we feel
incredibly lucky to have dr. Howell
Avenue with us today to share lessons
from a lifetime dedicated to the
selfless service of her people we have a
great deal to learn from the community
that dr. Abdi has both one that
continues to prioritize gender equality
and solidarity across ethnic lines even
in times of unimaginable hardship before
dr. Abdi and dr. Mohammed speak their
work will be introduced through the
following video produced in 2013 by the
vital voices global partnership which
works with women leaders to further
women's economic empowerment political
participation and human rights
my mother was dreaming that I will be a
great test with yoga she became pregnant
with his seventh child when I was 11
years old as head stomachs wealth she
felt weakness and pain
but she says no problem how everything
will be okay whether it comes to us
through violence disease or even child
back then it's not the end of our story
you have to get absent and someone who
needs you I became a doctor because I
wanted to sing other is fulfilling the
pain I felt when my mother died
Somalia I grew up in was so much
different and today Mogadishu was the
best place in all Africa in the total
area children had fresh clean fresh meat
fresh air life was very peaceful very
simple and the better taste it started
to go back in 1988 when the government
collapses were under more people come to
us to escape the fighting the Somali
people have tradition of hospitality
when a traveler comes to you you have to
give him the best of what you have it
seemed only natural that the problems we
could solve like giving someone a place
to stay and the feeling of service
should be solve it when space became
full family began to sit under the trees
after more than 20 years became 90,000
people which people have became my
family here we are also valid if you
want to identify with your friend
you cannot stay in time if my children
become doctors and now we work it
together its crisis we face gives way to
the next a semi-group text control of
our area
sometimes these children with their guns
they for me you are an old woman you
cannot be attached I think and you are a
strong young man what have you done for
these people whether still fighting for
the same we have lost as many as 50
people today but we get up we go on
and then we have someone who needs us
today our won-soon clinic is a positive
grateful stuff Irie for the hope that
this will come that my children and my
grandchildren with something that Somali
I love until that time they can build on
what I have started
I am dr. Howard Abdi this is my vital
voice now Richard
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please join us in welcoming dr. hardy
and dr. Decker Muhammad once again so
thank you so much for coming here as I
said this is a true honor to have you
here on Yale's campus and to talk to
this wonderful audience who's here to
learn about your work with hawa Abdi
village and in your long career of
service to Somalia I just wanted to
start by asking you a question about
what you remember growing up in the
Somalia that had undergone so many
changes from Independence onwards and
how you came to the decision to become a
doctor to serve your people
she learned I want to hint when I said
Anne died my mother I think that and I
decided that time to become a doctor
this is motherís life my father was kind
and he was intelligent all his friends
come that time to send their girls
outside was very difficult for Somali
traditional way but he said to me
because he could and he he was
understanding that is telling its very
best weeks of life he sends me to Soviet
Union and when my dream became
when my dream became over I decided to
study well when I wanted to Soviet Union
I was studying night and they became a
doctor to save another my virus so I
finished my study after the seven days
of the seven years I came back I began
to work to hospitals big hospitals in
Mogadishu I have seen that the chest is
slept well good then I began to study a
Faculty of Law in 1972 I finished 1971
where the whole school and I change also
the lawsuit
I was working because the talent but
always they were plotting us a mother
who is already nearly 2 died because she
lost a lot of blood or the child is not
family that little it was very difficult
in Terraria they were bringing us many
mothers were staying before we done
nothing so i decide to to go the route
early to help women rural area so how
long were you working in Mogadishu
before you decided to open the clinic I
finished 71 and I will house the rural
areas 1983 and did you continue your
relationship to the hospital and
Mogadishu or did you completely distill
the brand new role I was having
Mogadishu what it does with my friend
were there working and we were they were
coming sandy we have Fridays
on Friday if they were coming to me
because the sickly sometimes they want
to go outside think presbury's to fresh
air we were having this relation with
the big hospitalist in Mogadishu
but at 1990 it broke out Civil War this
civil war is costing across Africa all
we have this is which called tribalism
tribalist tribalism to plan was
pretending to fight one color will be
stronger than other one week they will
keep and destroy or the proquest you say
a little bit about what your clinic was
like before the civil war broke out in
1995 again they want to clean it
wonderfully but those the total area
sometimes they don't want to go to the
hospital is they prefer a traditional
businesses since to convince them was
very difficult but at last they
understood that the hospital can help
them so they come to me many patients
they did handed about numbers my number
was hundred today at the peak 100
protesters yes yes but at first if you
have difficulty getting getting local
people to come to the clinic is that
what you were saying between you know
twenty ten or twenty before only
territorial today's first few days then
we began to with my brother there Co
going to the small small village every
Friday and to ask if there is it a child
ship or a woman tick or we have plenty
of malaria
we were doing our where the scene I was
chatting when I because a white coat the
children first time they were running
from us then yeah that said that because
the child when he was once a child sick
death I was Christmas away and we played
since I visited we have our already seen
I will write a description that I will
bring I was mr. would give her the child
we just sick or woman and how it was
that Oh at the time when you she was
traveling with you in the rural areas I
was 10 or 12 I think
yes very yes it was really she was
really very very small I think what she
meant because of Somali culture and
tradition hospitals seen as a death play
so because they are arriving the patient
come to the hospital last minute and
were we don't have a well-equipped
hospital so we losing a lot of patients
so they see it's a disaster place to go
so when in the beginning they didn't
come to her she came up with this and
mobile clinic where we go out and go to
them in the village and it was very fun
to just be around and traveling as a kid
we were just having a fun so I learned
all the medicine antibiotics paracetamol
if there's names and they're just like
give 10 15 so we were being hired from
that I was a pharmacist earlier than
before I was on the doctor did you
incorporate traditional methods of
healing as part of your practice with
traditional medicine with a mission
practical something sometimes I was will
sometimes more effective than a vision
that we've seen the other mother than
would see especially in Africa so I
imagine this must been a very peaceful
time of practicing before the war that's
very very peaceful time
and so can you describe how it changed
after the outbreak of the Civil War
how did that avenge your clinicals of
disastrous it was no one will go his job
Africa we live remember we have fun and
finest and anomalous especially women of
Africa's very strong they were carrying
their family their hand because they are
digging fun wearing the anomalous and
they are carrying with their children on
bareback so you had a difficult time
after work out Civil War because no one
can go and do this job
do you still remember the first families
that came to your clinic for assistance
people coming continuing me to come to
me all my friends who wore equipment
last person when handed 1500 thread
ministers 1500 families in the first
week or in the first even first month
movie and then I know from reading the
autobiography that they just kept coming
yes yeah family left good pipe it till
they reach 15000 them at what point was
it that I reached 15,000 families after
how many months years two years or more
no years we have to become 2008 when the
word exacerbated and all three million
of muscial residents just had to flee
couple of days because a severe crash
happened between the government and
server benito bein was invading that
time was islamic court so it was a
political mass so the city become a
battle zone so three million people had
to sleep and in our hospital is right
the road where you leave the city we
only 20 kilometers away from addition so
that's why we were just took as much as
we
and not when it reached up to 90,000 we
didn't had any space to have them so we
just had to follow anybody did it to
feed them or to to give water so I began
to appeal the international
organizations like iced tea as she like
level you FP y ownership and MSS it
comes to me immediately giving me food
my ID which people under giving me a
field was he had a well but she drink
water I didn't feel they were giving
with your food children they will kill
Bush medicine is giving - when she I
imagine when it first began you weren't
you had no idea how long it would go on
for and of course it went on for decades
I'm curious at what point did you
realize this wasn't just going to be a
temporary shelter or a relief center
business international organizations
they were giving us the plastic shelters
cosmati and education movement and comic
the refuge beginning I was always
thinking that maybe one week after
become this but this went far far far
till now for 27 years
yeah so can you describe what clearly he
went through many many hardships and
dealing with the magnitude was that it
was seeing very bad things you know get
out with bothering poor people and
treating Beth but you cannot do nothing
you have only one person women in Africa
was very she could you know
witness it many plastics you created a
state within state for that 25 years and
after these people are fighting because
by force of clam and after that we have
traveled tribalism which is worse
identities travel as an enforcement
terrorist I person may have where were
receiving terrorist because terrorists
if you get along and by were you can
eradicate but tribalism to plan will
fight some will be beaten but those
quran was written they will tell the
older children are those children i will
tell other other children but never
finish generations generations so that's
why you started the law i think so Adam
family to strong feminine and weak when
will they fight the throw family will
come and beat those weak family which is
my village so I thought how to live with
these people how to come and I said but
we with an internal rules
I don't know knock like division in
Somalia if you come to my village
you are Somali on this if you are is
wrong it's up to you you go your
girlfriend if you come to me I will give
you space to leaf green water hair to
what the tree if you are began to to to
say that I'm that clan
I read this Weakland he will go so the
people in my village became equal then
they do not fight fight another time
there was no powerful clan who was
pretending it to do high of other
families they became equal we were able
to create the equal
like not allowing for Klan divisions yes
but instead being Somali yes so I'm sure
that was not an easy process were there
people who who still refuse to not have
their clan allegiances - yeah how did
you deal with that then after a few
months it begins a family violence the
men becoming to beat their wife the
first man was working day and Cammy well
already already tired and he told his
friends now they are studying in under
the best plastic sheet plastic plastic
she-she my father mother and children
and when they took the beginning to beat
his wife but family violence it came up
up up children are running because they
are bailiffs her mother and her father
but father is spitting mother they are
running to me mama hawa our Father
spitting our mother
I have sent some people we have others
it needs to glue some musicians you
cannot feed yuca but we have I said
bring him and and with the gel and put
them in jail yes and they have we are
sisters we open some vocs people will
bring him and within the jail and you
should describe what the scale was
because I'm not sure everyone knows
lovely it was when they stood a storage
facility a search closet yeah yeah it's
a circus you sit down there but of the
human after few days
we are not talking with him till they
the elders and women argued that the
committee will decide this case he will
say this
so you basically created a rule of law
when they said that day but they fell by
a missile only through a simple rule if
you tell fitness Pharisee Somali in my
village they put them equal
without any but finding the victim is
wrong :
so everyone's equal no one pretending to
be or claiming to be from a billion or a
better plan yes in the second role
example the the women the men will stop
beating his wife violent yeah yeah and
it I heard it very effective being in
the storage closet it is effective if
you're in a dark small room with a bunch
of food facts around you and you get
this a clusterf all day and that little
thing but it works most of it majority
of the time but it took I think with my
mom is persistent and 25 years of living
there so in the beginning people left
some of them there was some clashes but
finally by the time I arrived in 2007
the rule was in the place so that they
were teaching me some of the for God I
was there in the beginning with the
roohorse implemented like make sure if
there is any domestic violence you
immediately address the husband like
okay I will do it the committee was
telling me one day or knows that like
that's it that's the rule your mom did
it so my mom basically acts at the
Supreme Court the Supreme Court they
tell me to decide how things should go
the yard they use the young generation
who grew up in the cam are doing the
police action you know arresting and all
that but my mom is a fine and if they
cannot decide this is the Supreme Court
where we should appeal if we could not
decide the case yourself
because finally my all my friends and I
we used to have the fun is in my mom you
never get to practice your law so this
is opportunity just to practice you
after the word it says yes and also it's
a society of my village that's great
what about maintaining structure and
order in terms of food distribution and
resources and water when all of that is
in such short supply it must be very
challenging to be as fair as you
possibly can with all the needy families
we decide we divide into village six but
every part they were having their
committee will please you spices food
water and also cleaning to the village
sanitation integrally we are a sensitive
this committee and I think the majority
was made more beautiful the structure
and system is people find in life
because majority of the cam is and IDPs
internally displaced people in Somalia
they're just sitting and waiting Aid or
there is a clash is happening so within
our village they have a life they wake
up in the morning the elderly gather and
they decide what is the problem next how
we could solve the young generation
cleans up you know acts as a pulley so
you could feel you know become more
alive so you don't have to keep telling
them it's part of their daily routine
and they take very proudly they say oh
we are how up the village we have this
this is our rules they tell everyone who
comes to it so it was fascinating me
being after ten years away and coming
back and seeing the transformation
so one of the most well known incidents
that made international headlines was in
2010 when his Bulls mom basically tried
to take over the camp and my
understanding is you were put under
arrest
they were trying to force you to
relinquish control smells and pigs in
that video
yeah mm in hates me become group of the
Flemish she's police love bacon and they
say you are woman and old you cannot
scientist come with these people you
over you have to cover hand and keep a
single command very young and we are man
okay I see you have meant because you
have to test this but good also okay
you're both doctors yeah no our sisters
George also hospital what do you have
themselves they're a society the people
work with me becomes you keep quite they
making it kill you no I say I will tell
with the truth what they have done this
is their society but they are telling it
to tell me over and over this camp or
this village you are women and old you
cannot run this job you cannot you are
not in position to run this village I
think I am sorry you did not done
nothing the society if you have here you
have your values after you were you not
scared at all during this whole time
because they had weapons if I understood
it wasn't me
one of my friends but you take how deep
could not say nothing like men w
Muhammad oh yeah so but they comment
attacked and after few days they
surrounded us understand all the weapons
with heavy sharing in the hospital micro
meanwhile in my house in the bracelet
with the affiliation work in maternity
work days changes at that time there was
a watery diarrhea many children were
admitted in that PDA 3s work with the
few fluid water in the band so the
hospital was working fully yes and there
is a there were a woman where we operate
it I operated c-section I took a child
they're wearing on their pets but after
heavy sharing data and some one of the
loose woman ability a force each but
luckily patient didn't die one of our
security guards passed away I don't know
was killed during the attack then they
come and say the house dog during the
attack my daughter is conducting a BBC
somali somali language august and i i
tell that i super son attacking me and
my people now yeah they wanted destroy
our hospitals and my people i don't know
how many will remain I made yes what big
was and all the Somali he
they they come they they come the after
and they you talk outside if you're a
mobile with me where five my lips they
took all our Alamo pipe labor belted
minibus we stand up nice s okay I stood
up our children rather less also stand
it up come I I went after them we all
went after them they put us a minibus
all the people were crying
we thought that we will kill us it's not
too bad they brought somewhere where
they have their offices and they close
one room so they basically arrested you
and have you there in ten hours
yes then I was I was we were just under
house arrest
yeah no yep before the house arrest he
took it to their place in after she live
broadcast I had before although yeah
photo group they bring me my my fantasy
you have many supporters tell your
people that we don't have you I will
just your fifth your head I I took that
my daughterís as I see I have my life
I'm okay I have no problem and I was it
was the longest 10 hours of my life I
think so we didn't know where she is for
her persistent and being strong but
still we were all claiming her in some
house you know she shouldn't say resist
them but we are lucky to have her back
the live broadcast I think it made them
more aggressive and made the more mad
because the whole
over the Somalia was listening they're
shelling in in radio the whole country
to is checked like how in the world you
can attack a hospital especially mama
hawa so everyone was calling them and
then they get very scared and they give
her the phone and say you need to talk
to your people you still alive we didn't
kill you just tell them so they get off
of our shoulders you know they pushing
us making sure your life and she talked
to them no she talked to us and we told
you know all our killing my friends your
life then they tell her we destroy your
home we're going to take you somewhere
tonight and she say no you have to take
me back to my home I'm going to die in
my home if I'm dying
I would die with dignity so they brought
her back to the home and had a home
arrest for ten days and was unique I
think my mom is not sharing and it's
it's amazing we like the family whole
country like we are relieved today
released her she's home and we want
everything the work and to resume and
everything let's forget about what
happened no she insisted she say no I'm
not starting anything unless they
apologize so it's like what the hell mom
I'm begging you this is enough you know
you were a budget kicker killed and you
know we have a lot everything destroyed
we have to rebuild basically the
hospital structure and everything she
say now now they have to write a policy
letter
it's not even 1/3 of it one is for me
one is for the community and one for the
MSF that time is more Doctors Without
Borders were one in all vidya trick
section of the hospital and it took a
week conversation and back and forth and
we were all like okay
another attack can happen tomorrow so we
didn't know but the finally we were
surprised they wrote the letter and one
letter in three three left three men and
a Brooklyn like mama Howard this is your
letter so let's open the hospital
because
amazing I really admire her courage I
think it is the first time in history of
Somalia someone not only stood up to the
Warlord's and Islamist but also taught
them a lesson you need to apologize what
you have done was wrong
so since 2012-2013 much more peace has
come to Somalia yeah it would love to
hear what the work has been like since
pieces and been more able to stabilize
the country and make the work what much
less dangerous than these years that
you're describing from 2010 season yes
and I believe we had some photos of some
of the workers yeah yeah I will share
with you some photos your foundation
that's a beautiful photo of glamour in
2001 he received glamour Woman of the
Year clear vast me and my mom and my
sister and it took two hours to take
that track hahaha
after this photo I have deep respect for
models in the video I was thinking it
was very easy to take photos before
makes you fly stupid so that's the
hospital and this photo I read in the
one of my favorite photo because it's
super busy it's the outpatient you see
the you know the religious registration
is going on the PPD checking the Wade
you know mothers are lining up it's this
is the peak when we had over 90,000 and
daily we were receiving 500 and other
patients next slide so this is the
medical outreach mobile clinics we do in
the village to still do we try to keep
as soon as we get some window for safety
in area to go we go out it's very
beautiful it's very rewarding to go and
visit and just take all your medicine
with you there's nothing in there and
mothers are lining up waiting for your
next flight this is the primary school
the school is very dear to me and
favorite image education I loved it and
the one in my high school my country
fall apart so still stick to my
so [ __ ] school was opened in 2000 it
has a different story where we opened
and it didn't work and we open and it
closed but since 2008 and now nine years
is the school function functioning fully
this is the primary school next slide
with my mom in the middle of it we took
this photo the really distributed the
shirt this is the pre-k preschool we the
toys was delivered from Washington DC
and Seattle provider voices to be very
grateful which I tried my best to have
as any preschool in the world so they
can have the games and education in
early age and we'll prepare for them in
the future next slide and this is one of
my favorite photo of the primary school
next slide and this photo was taken by
New York Times when they visited in our
primary school it was for over seventy
thousand seventy twenty seven thousand
kids were out of the school and we could
only have in the school
eight hundred so very small numbers when
we say eight hundred people think oh
it's a lot but comparing to the kids out
of the school it's crazy and what I want
to really mention here today this photo
was taken three four years ago but these
kids are now in high school and they
taking this class Deb Nicola and
Charlotte was talking on the hope is
here and then and all this came together
because of Sarah Lulu we I I want to
teach my mom always tells you know the
problem in tamales people they don't
know their rights and that our law is
speaking and and that's what I decided
to do it and really yell and yell law
school initial shell Center helped to
put this program together and we have
very big ambitions and we're in the
beginning thinkin maybe just have one
year then every year we keep hiding you
we could improve in now we are four
years program and we hoping to take this
not only in our high school and all over
Somalia and teach the kids the conflict
resolution how this could work next
slide this is the map
of the village in Google Earth I just
took it yesterday night so if you go
look at it I just wanted people to
understand how did you know the mass if
it is and how people are driven in and
why we call in village and not come
anymore because people were there for 26
years and now we have more concrete and
structures in the place not only plastic
sheets and just to dignify you know how
they mobilize how they organize
themselves so this is all awesome
especially if I can point but it's going
to work or not oh yes that's the school
that's the high school we just build it
and it has a huge playground so the kids
kept our partners so this is all a small
structure at the hospital and this is
the primary school beginning this is the
road the main road so this is the first
settlement and this is the football
ground and this is the other settlement
each settlement we alpha this is the
back where we have a mango trees this is
the my mom's what she calls calm David
she gets rest too goes back there after
all crazy work is going on in there so
it's a very massive and this part of the
road it's our land but we also
responsible of 6 kilometers around us so
the UN and international community when
there's funding and food distribution we
cover all all area next slide and this
is how we decide actually we have the
committee and there's no office there's
no city hall you go if everyone comes to
the Camp David under the mango trees so
does the mango trees and solving a case
and we had a visitors this young
diaspora boys and girls came to visit
and see how we could solve daily cases
and discussion between them so I want to
take the took the photo next slide and
this is the daily new arrivals because
the you have a crash people will come
the village and the town is known ho all
over Somalia so they come for temporary
when their village gets quietly go back
their city so we do have
every day every other day new arrival so
every week might be to three families
the minute they arrive we try to
register and give whatever food we have
or plastic sheets and find places to
stay if they have already relatives in
the village they will stay with their
relatives next slide and this is another
new arrival is just waiting outside of
the hospital in front of the hospital to
see structure next slide and I wanted
this little bit talk about the drug
absolutely mixed it's a drought and it's
it's really heartbreaking it's all you
want to go forward we have a government
system in a place that have been here
during my wonderful year we'll follow
program six months then as soon as I
went to home made the drugs there the
election and I felt like we going
backwards instead of forwards so it was
a very tough time for me and it was very
hard to to see same drugs we have seen
even worst in 2011 so 2011 all war
supported Somalia was there we we did
fun vision and everything and after
short you know five years you're still
in the same place and there's no
structure in anything so we gathered a
lot of young Somalis come together with
all our frustration we said okay let's
use our frustration something good so
let's not wait until international
community reached us with NGOs everyone
we pledged a Nabil outside let's do
something inside and that worked and so
we created a mobile system we started
feeding we started putting every ten
kilometers some feeding centers we
gather together information then in
dilemma come in it's like we don't know
where we helping we don't know who is
we're helping so next slide this is the
feeding centuries now we have in and
this is for the children the beginning
we do the Porsche cook and all our we
took this food from the local stores
from the business guys so we didn't even
wait until money comes we call everyone
who knows in diaspora please send $100
$50 buying a food collecting the food
high school students going out to the
homes and stores asking food so that's
what how we mobilize next slide next
slide to choose the children in the
morning breakfast oh it's gone the right
oh ok ok so I want to just go back to
that mob next slide this is the food for
the rice we cook for the adults next
slide and next this is the map I just
want to talk
what it's the drought and how how how we
can reach people where we are reaching
where people are dying and as we know
that when the drought comes there is not
enough water and it's all preventable
diseases come so in immediately like
three weeks when I was back in Somalia
the watery diarrhea broke out in in our
village not too far we have enough water
but next neighbors and we lost two kids
immediately first couple days and it's
preventable it's very frustrating being
in this situation so we created this
unique map with young Somali diaspora in
Sweden in Holland in London gathering
together using technologies today given
this information and you only see the
red area is the world we have a death
orange is a food it's in needed and in
green where we have NGOs we know someone
is there and we need we need to call
that in geo so we communicated within a
one month we put whole country map this
United us there's no division in Somalia
we didn't care is that they also up area
or someone else we had to care people
where they died and young people United
and then gather together for only the
situation in drought if something good
came out but it's very frustrating to me
to be in that situation and also it's
very
empowering we could do something we
could make a difference before even
anyone gets there and before
international community reached us and
we reduce the number of death for
diarrhea we reduce the number of death
for starvation and this project is still
going on we have the website now and
Minister of humanity entities are
working with us to put information in
our website
Ohi UN is following our website we put
the report it's very easy simple thing
everyone can go in and put the
information with the phone and four of
us who verify is this true or not so we
call everyone when we have verified is
really tool we will follow and they will
ask who the closest one to distribute
food or water to the more medicine even
so that's how we mobilize in and it's
amazing and then it's good too but we
have to have more sustainable programs
in the country so that's the next slide
think I am done that's the future
generation of Somalia future leaders
here this is one of my favorite photo in
the village thank you so much this is I
think a great place to end with thinking
about all the amazing work that you've
been doing for those many decades the
work that you're still doing and then
the hope in Somalia future so thank you
for being here today
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so we're going to bring the lights back
up in the house and we will if all of
you have questions that you want posed
to doctors Abdi and Mohammad we'd be
very happy to have a few of them I think
we have a little bit of time for
questions so I think everyone has should
have a paper-and-pencil
so if you could pass your questions
there aids coming down the aisle to
Chloe and if you do not have a paper and
pencil just raise your hand and someone
and one of the age should get to you so
Mariah
I think people raising their hand if
they want a paper or pencil we're going
to question and thank you so much
I want to go VIN thank you for coming
and sharing my history yes and I want
sense
I am also Yale University - giving me
this opportunity to see to see this
beautiful College thank you very much
thank you for coming professor
additionally
ma all right maybe we should just bring
some down because we can always keep
collecting okay okay you ready for the
first question okay what has your
experience taught you about the role of
humanitarian aid from foreign
organizations and their relationships
with local NGOs and not an easy question
I know it yes of course and I didn't
have a go back to humanitarian aid
Gandia they hated I an and I would do
away and you could do up that me take an
Australian thank you
oh it's a heavenly chariot is excellent
in disaster just to deliver one time but
when it comes to life for almost quarter
century it's a disaster
it's basically disaster you creating a
whole generation dependent on aid the
whole system of aid is not set up for
sustainability and for the future so
it's all same cycle your fan base you
finish the money you come back the
project and and billions of money was
wasted for last 20 years in Somalia 25
years and nothing is done so it's very
painful to me it's good to have a
military work but we have to restructure
and we think more sustainable way and
maybe use only what it needs for that
emergency it's not continuously it's not
effective but the service life yes it is
like so it's a double-edged sword
yep yeah in that way the second question
oh thank you for watching
this is so I apologize ahead of time
there's quite a few questions and we'll
do our best to get through as many of
them as we can
the second question is given your
experience you have both been called on
to join multiple peace conferences and
committees that aim to chart a peaceful
and politically sustainable future for
Somalia what has your experience been
like with these and what lessons can we
take away from these projects given that
many have failed in the past other
national money Thank You mr. Gomez ah I
have now monka Bernina I know that I
won't tell you that everything you want
you can reach just it needs to be
assistance and committee I think it's
impossible this work although this was
now especially outward spending enough
really clearly paying and the world is
Alex what is one human being is one
outlet this one every one of us
assistance ability to persuade this
world peaceful place because we want
with nicely and that depend on us if
people human being now this one
definitely this one
what is one where or one
yeah and what we learned from dealing
human the question was thinking of
questions you're captured I think some
part of it oh yes you did yeah
definitely good I have a question that
is in some ways a follow-up it says in
the face of tribalism war and famine how
if you found the strength to live and
love through it all I think what should
you what you want you want Somalis and
everyone to know about love who's kind
of a profound question and leave money
if Martinez an artifact on occasion
kkeokki city jail canada kaspersky
season this is God gave you the strength
yeah
nicolai to speak louder okay
but we've been listed yeah I think to me
is the people inspire me and I think my
mom also will say it's the people in
Somalia my people expect me loves me and
I love them I love my country and my
people I have all read in my life and so
do my people on the counter and they're
sitting and I'm getting also
international respect to other human
beings on this five continents yes yes
you most definitely have our deepest
respect oh dear it will be okay
we have a question here that wants to
have more details about the storage
closet is there anything more to add to
that question that story nothing much
really it's just it's just a way to
punishing the mistake has done so if you
let it go what happened and you say talk
about it and it's not going to be solved
but when you punishing in a soft way
because you have still conflict zone you
have trouble people you cannot just do
as a real gel or anything or have a
strong rules and law is just I think it
helped a lot and then it's basic some
days it's full we don't have space to
arrest anyone some some days the food
distribution time we don't arrest anyone
we try to find other rooms to close it
so that's that the way it works nothing
or special or fancy or you don't have a
specific gel funding for that all right
so this question is what was the most
difficult disagreement or conflict that
arose in how I of the village and that
you needed to resolve it might be
difficult to pick one but if you can try
holy but my analysis company behind so
stop land division when division brand
deletion that was very difficult for all
Africa and for follow for Somalia but I
really I win in my village there is no
current vision but all other countries
in Africa they have conditions even
Somali law
it's what I think we we always have the
conversation is the problem in how we
are very linked and tie and dependent on
clan because it's insurance basically
when you have a sick child or you desk
your client funds here so that's why the
people are dependent on the client issue
so I think the biggest issue assault is
to release this dependency to the client
so when people have opportunity the
hospital where they can bring their kids
when they sick you know the community
that supports them when they need things
I think the biggest problem she solves
she's not saying is just making teaching
people you don't have to be belonged to
client agency and I agree with them
wrong and right you can be independent
and have as a human being and support
your fellow humans I think that was the
biggest challenge I think she solved in
the camp but the daily case is one by
one it happens you know the worsen today
you you have a gun pointed on you and in
her kidnap situation to me was most the
hardest part so I think I'm going to
conclude by the truth there are two
quick comments I believe we might have
some Somalis in the audience who want to
express their thanks to you for all the
amazing work that you've done so I just
want to make sure to acknowledge that
voice of gratitude and then the last
question is how can we best support your
work you know fantastic in many many
ways you can join the wonderful two
programs going on in yell and the
business class injection supporting the
idea
and one of really what I needed my doing
Kieran and we talked a lot with my mom
my sister how we could be sustainable
how we could be independent how we could
create more jobs that brings the peace
understand stability in the country so
and we have a great opportunity here
Jackson Institute helping us to create a
business in FL state which is one of its
kind in the world I think so and we're
trying so you can get involved
physically or might be the school for
education program or the best thing is
given money go to the website so this is
one thing I learned so you cannot do
anything without money that's how we
creating the business we have to be very
honest to ourselves
the majority why this is Theta failing
because there's no funding the
government is weak and corrupted and
people don't have the money so when
you're you and you don't have a job you
will be able to do anything
thank you so much and of course we will
let you have the last word
so whatever last parting comments you
have all the audience please feel free
to share them is committed to be
invisibly Savannah my opinion power
I chose email being their one and then
we have to depend each other we have to
help each other we have to try to live a
peaceful and good life and that is we
can do we can do that if we know reality
that we are one everywhere for something
to happen one corner of this world that
a corner from spread and reach so we
have to stop every betting and help each
other I want to say that people has to
support each other has to prevent every
bad thing in this work and made this
world better place for this for living
for us for our children for our
grandchildren
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]